Let's get into the career of Dre.
The blossoming of Dre is now a solo artist.
You drop your solo project, holy sh*t, The
Chronic.
Dre now becomes a conversation of holy sh*t.
This is the guy.
What is the difference in you then than you
with the group, the solo success compared to
the group success? What was that change?
Well, I think
that the the difference there was.
Money and business got involved and it
separated the friendship.
So had to separate myself from easy because
he decided to take a different route.
Cube had already left.
So I'm out here on my own.
I have absolutely no idea what the f*** I'm
going to do. I just know I have this talent
and I've been developing these skills with
mixing and this whole sh*t.
And, close friend of mine, we call him DOC,
talked me into doing The Chronic album and,
I went in there and I went.
It wasn't even a decision.
No, it wasn't my decision.
I was talked into doing that.
Okay. And yeah, I just went in there and
went for it because I felt like at that time
it was a life or death situation.
Backs against the
wall. Back is against the wall, life or death
situation. And this record is going to
determine whether I'm going to stay in the
studio or not. Yeah.
This is, this is this is a career make or
break moment for you. Yeah, absolutely.
And by the way, that's when people do their
best work when you have no other choice.
All the eggs in one basket.
And either this basket is going to be
responsible for how I eat or it's going to
break. Yeah.
It's really weird. It's a really weird
dynamic moving forward.
It's like it's really tough to find that
kind of ambition and energy right now.
Today. Yeah.
You know.
I was going I was going to get to that.
But I like that you're there now.
Right. Because we're talking about the
difference in your then and of course
getting to your now.
But the group.
Phenomenal success.
Business economics, business deals done
right, wrong.
Separation. People go their separate ways.
But it doesn't mean sh*t if you're not
getting treated
right.
Okay. I don't give a f***.
I've walked away from millions of dollars,
Kevin. You know, it's.
If it's not right, I'm not with it.
Yeah. I don't give a f*** how much money
you're offering. Yeah. You know, I'm not
about to leave with a wet ass, you know what
I mean? I'm not doing that.
F*** that. Okay, you keep your money, I'm
taking everything with me, which is the
talent. Okay?
So I have absolutely no problem with betting
on myself, you know?
And. I'm going to win.
I always call myself a f***ing professional
winner.
I don't see anything wrong with that.
If you won and you have done it at the
highest levels, associating yourself in that
regard to me as a line, like I don't, I
don't. That doesn't make me go, whoa, I get
it. I'm a guy that goes, I get it.
Oh, yeah, you feel like you won because I
left all this money for you?
Yeah, yeah. You have that moment.
Have your f***ing 15 minutes.
Yeah. Guess what I'm about to do.
I'm going to go do it again. But this time do
it double. Yeah.
And every time it gets bigger and bigger and
my the ultimate form of revenge for me is
success. I'm going to keep being successful
and make you look like sh*t.
Yeah, that's what it is.
If you've done. If you've done me wrong.
Yeah.